what you need to know about cop27 since
1995 the United Nations has organized an
annual conference for nearly 200
countries to talk about the climate
crisis delegates and ministers from
these countries have butted heads to
find ways to cut emissions and adapt to
a warming planet
[Music]
so what is it that delegates will talk
about at the beach resort town of
charmal Sheikh in Egypt this November
get ready for some jargon first loss and
damage under the Paris agreement signed
in 2015 rich countries promise to pay
for losses and damages caused in poor
countries by climate change however
until now countries have not discussed
who will pay how much they will pay and
how that money would be transferred with
a third of Pakistan underwater only a
few months ago the debate around loss
and damage is expected to be a hot one
at cop27. second what does Africa need
this will only be the fifth time a cop
meeting has happened in Africa as the
continent that has contributed the least
to climate change but it's suffering its
worst impacts there will be a much
needed focus on Africa's needs those
needs will be met through financial
grants technology Partnerships and
bilateral deals expect lots of
announcements that will be called
memorandum of understanding third is
private cap Capital moving as expected
even though cop meetings have been
traditionally about government officials
meeting their counterparts private
companies have been playing a bigger and
bigger role that's because moving the
world to reach net zero emissions within
decades will require as much as four
trillion dollars of Investments every
year the vast majority of that money
will come from private players
cop 26 in Glasgow last year the world's
biggest financial institutions with more
than 150 trillion dollars of assets
under management committed to moving
their Capital toward the goal of
reaching net zero emissions by 2050. at
cop27 there will be a big focus on
finding out how they are progressing for
all of Bloomberg's coverage of cop27
please visit bloomberg.com